roland emerick has been doing some
interviews and he's been asked directly
about stargate what he had to say is
very very interesting
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so roland emrick's new movie moon 4 is
out at cinemas and to be fair it's not
done very well more importantly he's
been asked directly about the stargaze
series and his answers have actually
reinforced a lot of what i've been
saying over the last few months about
the return of stargate to our tv screens
so first of all he was basically
directly asked are you going to return
to do a stargate movie because he has
been lined up to do one before his
answer was
it's not going to happen
the reason why it's not going to happen
though is very telling he said i thought
that the people that watched the tv show
are the main focus that's a really
interesting point because i did a video
a little while ago about mgm we're
really considering three main options
for stargate plan a is a movie followed
by a tv series
plan b if the sale of mgm to amazon
drags on much longer they will start
with a tv series and then follow up with
a movie this is basically down to how
long it takes a movie to be produced and
how long it takes a tv show to be
produced obviously a tv show is much
quicker and they really have a deadline
that they wanted something on the
screens by and the end of 2023 so if the
sale drags on a long time they're going
to want to start with the tv series
because they can get on our screens
faster than the canon movie they want
the movie first ideally because they
really want to build a lot of hype up
plan c
was to actually do a hard reboot now
roland emmerich and dean devlin many
years ago this actually when the first
stargate movie came out always planned
that movie to be a trilogy but it got
turned into the tv series eventually now
he actually says in this interview that
he was offered to do the tv series
himself he actually did look into it but
he said everything he does has a certain
production value and basically the
amount of money they were offering pers
tvs episode the budget was only about
eight hundred thousand dollars at a time
when the x-files was getting made for
over a million dollars an episode so he
basically felt it's not going to be
enough money i don't want to do
something that is half-hearted so he
decided not to do the sg-1 series but
his point about the fans of the tv show
being the focus for producers really is
internet again underlies what i've been
saying for a few months
that they do not want to do a hard
reboot of this series they want to do a
soft reboot a continuation of the story
this really does confirm now that plan c
is out of the window we will not be
getting a hard reboot of stargate we
will only be getting a soft reboot and a
continuation of the sg-1 sg universe and
sg atlantis series now i did actually
tell you in a video a few months ago the
role of denmark was actually in meetings
with mgm and amazon executives in
november apparently the existing plan
for the trilogy was pitched once again
to those people
and they were seriously considering
doing this actually having a full hard
reboot i've done a video actually
talking about why they thought about
that because you know it is a lot easier
to do a hard reboot in lots of ways
you've got a lot of canon you don't need
to worry about too much so
in some ways it's better but it's not
what we want and amazon i know it's not
what we want as fans but what roland
emerick here is saying it basically
confirms that those meetings actually
did happen
now
i don't know exactly what happened in
those meetings my source at mgm who told
me about this just is aware that they
did happen but from what ronald emmerich
here is saying it looks like these were
early discussions they were sort of
putting the idea out there roland rick
said what he would want and amazon
basically said no
but there is another reason why those
meetings happened it turns out the role
of limerick is still actually contracted
to mgm and stargate he actually says
that if there is a movie or a series of
movies produced that he will have to be
involved in some way because he's
contracted to do so now obviously mgm
could not trigger that contract they
could decide not to but if they want
roland emerick to be involved in some
way he will be now even though he says
he is not going to be involved directly
in the movie in in a directing or
writing approach and he will have to be
involved in some way but but not as much
as he won't be show running it he does
actually go on to say that he really
hopes they will make a movie on a series
of movies i think he's actually saying
this because he knows that's the plan
from the meetings he would have had with
mgm mans and he knows that the plan is
to produce a new movie
when that movie comes out is gonna very
much dependent on the sale like i say
but roland emerick is kind of if you
read between the lines confirming that
actually that is the plan and that is
something that they are seriously
considering so to wrap that up in a nice
little bow
wrong denrick is basically confirmed to
us if you read between the lines that a
movie is at least being considered
he's also confirmed to us that these
meetings did happen um towards the end
of november like i reported previously
but most importantly he has confirmed
that for mgm and amazon the tv audience
the tv fans the fans of sg-1 and sg
atlantis st universe are their main
focus
so for me that basically underlines and
means that plan c is
completely out of the window we will not
be getting a hard reboot of stargate and
all i can say to that is
hallelujah one last thing roland rick
actually did say in this interview with
space.com though is that he's not
actually considering doing any more
science fiction novels except maybe one
the forever war has been in
pre-production for a very long time um
channing tatum was actually signed on to
do this movie got seven years ago but it
never happened ronaldo has said that is
the only science fiction novel that he
would be interested in
so very possibly we might be getting a
forever war movie or maybe even a tv
series at some point in the future if
roland emerick gets his way i haven't
actually seen moonfall yet but i love a
lot of roland and rick's previous work
he's a bit hit and miss for me but as a
filmmaker he's great and i think
actually with a source material
something like the forever war he could
create something great
so
get into the comments tell me what you
think am i reading a bit too much into
this interview perhaps or do you think
that actually yeah roland is confirming
a lot of what i've been saying for the
last few months and if you are new to
the channel please like subscribe hit
that bell notification it really helps
us out you can also join the channel and
become a fully fledged side tracker hit
the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see